most writers now are making it a line of
dialogue in which a character directly
States the theme okay like the second
Wonder Woman movie there's that opening
sequence
how is story Maps different from other
methods that are out there say like save
the cat
save the cat I have a lot of problems
with
um
I think it did a really good job at the
time it came out of uh making beat
sheets and dramatic elements in a
screenplay more accessible to
newer writers
but I don't agree with a lot of Blake
Snyder's uh categorizations I think that
his method the original Blake Snyder
beat sheet was designed for his genre
which is family comedy commercial family
comedies or high concept High concept
comedies
um like he used Miss Congeniality as one
of his pure examples in the book and it
was a great example and it's it's good
screenwriting it's a high concept fun
movie but it does I don't think his
method applies to every genre whereas I
think my story map
is General enough that it can apply to
any genre and in my books I do break
down movies of all genres and then now
with TV TV shows of all genres
with save the cat the beat sheet
specifically there are Beats in there
that I just don't think are Beats okay
so it opens with
opening image while an opening image
isn't a beat it's just that first
description first thing you're looking
at when you start a script
and so he was saying that opening image
is so important that we're going to put
it in this 10B beat sheet well I can
tell you from being a reader you forget
about the first thing the first
description on page one by the time
you're halfway down page one okay the
thing that you're looking for is
is what is this compelling story what is
the drama what who is the main character
and what's going to suck me in and if
you can do it with an opening image
that's great but that's very rare and I
don't think you as a writer should kill
yourself trying to think of an opening
image it's better to say that first beat
is you're opening it's that page one to
ten
um and specifically right off the bat
one to five is really key it's how are
you starting off this story you know
what's the first thing we see like in
Breaking Bad it has that great Flash
Forward opening you know
um and there is an opening image in
there uh in the original pilot script
for Breaking Bad I think it was a pair
of pants flying through the air in the
desert and then the um the RV like hits
the pair of pants and keeps keeps
shooting down the road and so now we're
following the RV and then we meet Walt
but see the fact that I can't remember
what that opening image is is kind of a
testament to it didn't really matter
because it was a great story and that
was a great sequence so that's an
example
um the next one either two or three uh
in the Blake Snyder beat sheet is called
theme stated and he says you want to
show something or have a line of
dialogue that shows the audience or
reader what is the theme of this story
well the problem is that most writers
now are making it a line of dialogue in
which a character directly States the
theme okay like the second Wonder Woman
movie there's that opening sequence
where the Young Wonder Woman as a girl
is going through this uh this like trial
obstacle course thing it's a race and
she's trying to win and she takes a
detour because of factors that happen on
the race and then when she's almost
winning or maybe she wins I don't
remember her mother Robin Wright
grabs her and says you cheated you don't
cheat in life Diana and that was stating
the theme and I think that that writer
was like oh we have to have theme stated
on page three of this screenplay and
minute five of the movie but that's not
a beat that's just telling the audience
and a telling not showing because a lot
of writers unfortunately aren't going to
show it in a really active
compelling surprising way
that's not a beat that advances the
story necessarily now if you can combine
it with something that advances the
story that would be great
but you don't always need it in that
position so I tell my writers express
your theme
through the actions through the Beats
you know through the drama of the story
it should be clear to us what this is
about you know it doesn't have to be
right away that you can settle into that
as you go on through the pilot or the
script
so but it should be clear eventually
that this is what this story is about
this is what it's exploring but to say
it directly to State it I think is two
on the nose
where is Sid field his teachings
resonated with you
yeah yeah I mean he was the original and
um I mean I don't remember if he said
show don't tell in his book then but he
probably expressed that you know this is
a visual medium and so you want to show
us something
um rather than explaining everything in
dialogue
just just to play Devil's Advocate do
you think that at the time Sid field
wrote his book and and then the time
that Blake Schneider wrote his book that
just the audiences were receiving
content in a different mindset
I mean Pro I will say prob probably
movies were Tighter and shorter when
Blake Snyder
put out his first book you know if you
look at films from like the 70s and
early 80s which I think sidfield's book
came out in like 80 or 81.
um they are looser in storytelling
they're slower and they last longer so
um you know they act one of a movie in
the 70s might be more like 40 45 minutes
but by the time you get to the 90s it's
almost always 30 minutes around 30
minutes you know and there are a lot of
classic movies that also have that
structure like Sunset Boulevard which I
break down in my book that's one of the
reasons I was blown away by it because I
watched it for the first time as an
adult and it's like exactly 100 minutes
it's exactly in modern structure and
story map structure so I thought that
was really cool I know a lot of people
say they've seen the save save the
cateization of movies over time that
they they're just like okay that's
that's theme stated and that's Dark
Night of the soul and you can just go
down the go down the list
I don't I think that's probably a little
bit true that Hollywood maybe follows it
a little bit too much but that's true I
think that's true of cliche storytelling
in general you know there's a way to hit
this Blake Snyder beat sheet in great
surprising compelling ways like we've
talked about just as there are in my
beat sheet for story Maps you know what
is a story map a story map is by a very
powerful tool that I developed from
being a reader and a writer and um
studying lots of classic movies and
television shows because I have
different story map templates for TV and
for film
and basically it's a very powerful
outline that breaks down the
foundational elements of your story
which I call the basic story map and
those are those uh basic really
important things your protagonists their
external and internal goal the theme the
central dramatic question to the story
which is kind of like the main engine
the obstacles standing in their way and
you have to really have that stuff
before you go to the beat sheet which is
your signpost Beats the markers in the
story
and for example uh I give them names
like opening and citing incident strong
movement forward uh event and turn at
the end of act one and it's split into
act one act two a act 2B act three uh
with TV one hour TV is usually uh teaser
plus 4X or teaser plus 5x and then half
hour TV is usually teaser or cold open
plus 3x
and so I break it down very specifically
uh into page ranges you don't have to
hit a specific page point but it should
generally be in that in that range
because that is the industry standard
and I learned this from studying
professional screenplays for both film
and TV and I saw what do the pros do you
know what is it that is um
bought and sold what establishes a pro
writer versus an amateur
and they do use this basic structure
which I call the story map
how is the story map different from
everything else that's out there
well I think my uh categories and
categorization is different than other
methods I think it's more specific I
think it's more based on
uh professional work and successful work
in both the movies and television I
think I've probably analyzed more films
and TV than a lot of authors of other
books I mean I don't know for sure but
um I know I've spent a lot of time on my
method and I developed a lot of it while
I was on the job working as a
professional reader for studios and
production companies so I know that it
also has an industry standard element to
it and a professional element to it
but as far as the um the categorizations
like in my beat sheet I think I I go
into more detail in describing them so
that there's more guidance for the
writer
give a story map that you can show us
from a popular movie in your book
um yeah my original book story Maps
which is uh how to write a great
screenplay it's about movies about
features
um there's a lot of great movies that I
break down in here
um
As Good As It Gets is one that I really
like it's a romantic dramedy there's a
lot of Comedy there's a lot of drama
and it pretty much follows uh the story
map really well it's a little bit longer
of a film but I believe the First Act is
definitely around 30 30 minutes you know
which is pretty standard even with
longer films the first stack tends to be
about half an hour
it's just kind of uh the way
storytelling has evolved on screen but I
just think it's a great example of
Storytelling
for film really compelling protagonist
he's got a lot of quirks and
misbehaviors you know he's his main one
is OCD he's obsessive and he has this
germaphobia and that's getting in the
way of his
any relationship whether it's his
friendship with his neighbor with his
gay neighbor
or his uh possible relationship with his
waitress Helen Hunt and so he's been
pushing people away this whole time but
his true goal is to let people in you
know to actually develop healthy
relationships is there any way you could
take us a little bit through the story
map for As Good As It Gets I know
there's a lot of
moments it might be too sure yeah
there's a lot of Great Moments um Let me
refresh myself with my book here
um I love the opening it establishes
Jack Nicholson
um as just this really cantankerous guy
and it kind of shows us everything about
him
um
a woman a neighbor comes to his door or
he walks out his door and there's a
neighbor who says it's tulip season it's
such a it's such a wonderful day I'm
going outside and and she sees him and
just glowers at him like she knows this
guy just puts the kibosh on any fun and
then uh Melvin Udall Jack Nicholson
finds his neighbor's dog sniffing around
and he doesn't like dogs
you know he's a germaphobe and
everything and he picks up the dog and
he stuffs them down the trash chute
and it turns out so then his neighbor
comes out which is Greg Kinnear looking
for this dog and he lies and says he
hasn't seen a dog you know so it's just
such a great way of just showing what a
jerk this guy is you know then he goes
back into his apartment and we see all
the OCD rituals you know he's washing
his hands with scalding hot water and
soap and he he um
turns the law he has a bunch of locks on
his door he turns them a certain number
of times and ways he has all these
rituals and those are going to tie in in
the end because when he finally uh
achieves his Arc and he gets Helen Hunt
to love him and he is selfless with his
neighbor and he's a good friend to his
neighbor he realizes he didn't lock the
door
so it's a visual device that he's gotten
over some of these uh problem you know
these problems and obsessions that he
had so they do it in a showing not
telling way